how to crank up real growth in Europe
and server over dependence on banks
innovation my challenge is how to unlock
investment in Europe's companies and
infrastructure for the long term for
this we need to build a true single
market for capital a capital markets
Union s emmys along supported as drivers
for growth but financing can be hard to
come by as banks find them too risky to
invest in there is a lot of financial
resources across the you and the word
and not enough financing for SMEs so we
will work here in order to make CMU also
a tool to support SMEs it's a big
opportunity but a lot of work to do but
there's a risk attached to the
interconnection of potentially 28
capital markets and what if there was
another financial crisis no SI DNT que
estamos mucho mejor preparados para una
cases financier Adele ok estamos hace
algunos años ya tenemos prácticamente
dos dos pilares de la union man caria
tenemos un sistema de bonanza que no
teniamos antes the capsule marchesini
and could be rolled out by 2080 but it
remains to be seen with a small and not
just medium sized businesses would in
fact be able to tap into the finance and
get the support they need to succeed and
grow